[Music]
la
aurora a privately run nature reserve on
the plains of eastern colombia
is home to many rare species of wild
animal
the vast grasslands are also home to
extensive cattle ranches
[Music]
jorge baragan's family has lived in the
region for generations
they own 17 000 hectares of land that's
almost
three times the size of manhattan
he's created the private la aurora
nature reserve on part of this land
because the habitats of wild animals are
shrinking fast
as forests are cleared away to create
pastures
and that's not the only problem jaguars
face here
populations across the region are at
risk of being wiped out
here on the plains jaguars kill about a
hundred carves and foals per year
most ranchers have no interest in
protecting the predatory cats
the greatest threat to their livestock
but ranchers are being asked to rethink
their approach
and to learn how to co-exist with the
big cats
in la aurora jaguars are protected and
may not be killed
baragan's nature reserve is affiliated
with the jaguar corridor initiative
run by the panthera ngo the corridor
stretches from argentina to northern
mexico
barragan collects data on the behavior
of the cats for panthera
they've installed more than 100 video
camera traps across the reserve
spots where jaguars roam which corridors
they use
we have so far identified two major
corridors in areas where they have a
better forest habitat
the one runs from east to west and the
other from north
the video recordings help them estimate
the jaguar population
and the animal's state of health if
they're doing well
it indicates that the ecosystem is in
good shape too
barragan has been observing the
movements of a certain four-year-old
female
he's named tortin he's looking for her
tracks and other traces
jaguars need large hunting grounds and
tend to move along well-established
routes
the savannah a mixed forest grassland
ecosystem
is being destroyed not just to create
pastures
but also fields for crops
nature reserves like la aurora are a
last refuge for wildlife
environment
more than 50 jaguars live here now
as well as lots of other species
um
[Music]
humans and their livestock have found a
way to coexist with the jaguars
what's more the beautiful cats are
becoming a tourist attraction
and that means a further source of
income for jorge barragan
[Music]
you